bolo's actually gonna [__] he might
be disgusting and probably he might be
it's like it's like a 50 50 chance he
just randomly shot through the garage
dude literally he shot at one spot he
completely flicked to the other side of
the garage and shot and killed me
okay
given the fact that he has so minimal
experience at that high of a level it's
really impressive how he's played but I
worry for him and I worry for his mental
state because I've seen the way that his
fans react when he doesn't do well or
when he doesn't get a kill in just one
round he can be top fragging the whole
game he goes one round without a kill
and half a twitch chat will end up going
all bolos wash get rid of bullet drop
over every
so close before but they've fallen short
and they'll do so again TSM said trust
the process the process just won you a
world championship
TSM are your six Invitational 2022 World
Champs
[Music]
Jason bolo Doty was born in Riverside
County California and moved to Las Vegas
at five years old in an all too familiar
scenario he first got into video games
because of his older brother with World
of Warcraft serving as his Gateway into
PC gaming I was the sports kid out of my
family or at my brother and I played
baseball like soccer basketball but my
brother then transitioned me to the uh
the side of video games
and I never never stopped as time went
on Bola moved on to Shooters
specifically CS go but in 2015 the
Rainbow Six Siege beta hooked him
instantly and never let go when I first
saw like the like the trailer it seemed
pretty interesting but when I started
playing the beta I got into the Beta it
was I I guess really just like love at
first sight I was I was hooked yo he's
not gonna see me are you serious
was good at Siege so good in fact that
he caught the attention of big streamers
and Pros hello hello Beulah oh Bueller
Beulah I don't know yeah and that's the
one call you Bo yeah bolo's actually
gonna he might be disgusting and
probably he might be it's like it's like
a 50 50 chance unfortunately not all
that attention was positive bolo skill
was drawing cheating accusations from
every level of the game
yeah okay and he just randomly shot
through the garage dude literally he
shot at one spot he completely flicked
to the other side of the garage and shot
and killed me and blowo is not there's
no this kid's not legit no drones Sprint
on in with the call out of there in
there in church and so he just Sprints
through nope I don't even I don't even
care if he's just gonna go use this in a
meme video I'm gonna report boylo every
single [__] time I ever play him at
this point since bolo was just a name in
Siege ranked he had no way to clear his
name other than uploading montages of
his gameplay to YouTube he doubled down
by streaming on Twitch in 2017 and
ironically his following exploded to a
level that left basically every one of
his accusers in the dust
[Music]
hey I appreciate that I'd say the whole
bolo lean kind of happened pretty
organically if you even look through
like my early montages like just watch
them through from you know one to one
three it's very slow and then once you
get deeper and deeper you start to see
it kind of come together like the really
fast you know what we all know today the
fast Ash ACOG Ella quick peeking you
know all over the place doing like 50
Lanes in like two seconds something like
that his influence on stage was so great
the game began to morph and shape itself
around how bolo played it we've seen
crazy players step forward but then he
comes forward and he does something that
a lot of people haven't and since then
we've seen a couple players that play
very similarly to him and it's cool
because it shows that there's a way to
play this game at a higher skill ceiling
than we thought before not only did bolo
prove he wasn't a cheater he became the
most popular content creator in Siege
thanks in part to his new off meta
strategies eventually his dreams got so
big he decided to put everything into
Siege he became a full-time content
creator choosing not to go to college
even when I was like at like 15 000 20
000 Subs I you know I was always telling
them like you know if this if this goes
somewhere I'm not going to pursue like
secondary education I want to do what I
want at the same time though boldo was
also kind of waiting out the clock until
he was 18. old enough to go pro his
content was huge but if he wanted to
truly show he was the best he'd have to
play against the best and he wasn't the
only one waiting days before his 18th
birthday bolo signed with one of the
biggest orgs out there TSM you know like
we knew a lot of people were going to be
looking around at bolo
um but apparently we were like the only
team like really interested in him I
guess because a lot of people were you
know very skeptical because there's a
big thing going on that like Butler's
gonna like he's good he has good aim
he's good mechanics but is he going to
be good like a comp setting and stuff
like that so a lot of people were
worried there by then bolo's fan base
had
being obsessed obsessed with their
favorite gamer so expectations were Sky
High for his Pro debut given the fact
that he has so minimal experience at
that high of a level it's really
impressive how he's played
but I worry for him and I worry for his
mental state because I've seen the way
that his fans react when he doesn't do
well or when he doesn't get a kill in
just one round he can be top fragging
the whole game he goes one round without
a kill and half a twitch chat will end
up going all bolo's washed get rid of
bullet drop below the people who know
the game well I think are aware of his
shortcomings and his strengths as a
player and so far he's done better than
a lot of us expected but matchmaking and
pro league were not the same thing and
boa learned that the hard way Goga
finishes off Polo and it leaves only
pojo man alive he does have a flight
capability though to try and move around
these players but it's already been
spotted and Fabian has it iced out
that's the end of the match ladies and
gentlemen G2 are moving through once
again to the semifinals and TSM The Last
Hope for North America is now out it
definitely is rough because you know the
first half of the season was I think
what we tied one game and won one and
lost all the other ones but three months
into his pro career bolo finally turned
it around and gave his fan fans what
they'd been waiting for they all collect
back in towards that diffuser in front
of the White Band beautiful shot there
from bows he ducks and darts around that
car outside that's going to trade though
but everyone at liquid solo HP
everyone's wrapping it up it's all Paulo
alone now in the 1v2 to keep liquid
alive as he comes down yellow stairs
there's no chance North American you
have another champion a tree that
Montreal wasn't just bolo's first ever
land win it also earned him an MVP medal
as well as some much deserved respect
I've definitely seen a a spike since
bolo has become you know what everybody
wants him to become in pro league or I
guess you know close to because I know
people have ridiculous standards for me
however Bobo struggled to keep the
momentum going Pinot's ready to hold the
line is he ready for the rotate from
lodgy though that's the next question
yes he is
[Applause]
push nip take control of the lower
bracket and the second spot in the grand
finals of si 2020. si 2020 was my first
ever event we got third and four
probably a year up until the next S.I I
would be just in bed staring at the
ceiling like
what went wrong that of them every
little flashback every little minute
detail any error that happened whether
it was my own or my teammates like we
were that close 2020 was a year of
almost with TSM placing second and third
at several high-profile tournaments
before capping the year was a big win at
the sixth major is it gonna be good
enough to possibly get an air jab that's
positioned there we don't know merc's in
the bomb site one for thinking they'd
Mark finds one Chala gets one as well
TSM they win it all every single kill is
theirs and they'll take the trophy as
well North America has a new Champion
why in a really impressive score line
unfortunately TSM went right back to
struggling in 2021. Shepard getting that
diffuser down and he will do so
successfully bolo trying to get back to
the site punished by Dan and Empire have
now a two-man lead from above that'll
grow to three as always shuts down Chala
and it seems like tsm's run here in
Mexico is effectively over pojo gets one
on the joystick but there's four more
bodies to find and they'll find him
first mozzie runs outside looking for a
kill but he doesn't come back to server
window but he will finally take down
Shala bolo needs to keep his team in
this match well down one player Nix with
dream on low HP this still might be
accomplishable for bolo but he needs to
hold for him counter to view his
attempts coming out from Knicks all of a
sudden it turns into a winnable
situation but it's not something he can
Stave off forever heartbreak for TSM FTX
Geo look into pressure five laundry I
like this there's a light that they're
pushing in from everywhere but right now
they can't win the gunfights nest of
Moringa managing to get kills Moringa is
traded out in there NES gets another and
surely this is the direction of liquid
balls through the smoke Paulo has no
idea how soon they come through it's
nescan sexy cake I'm sure you can hear
Team Liquid in the background they win
at this point bolo had enough followers
and clout to Simply throw his hands up
retire and go back to content creation
if he wanted to he'd proven he wasn't a
cheater got a lan win and shown that he
could hold his own online or off drops
the 80s and it's this week
down the core of long a triple fed to
him bolo also single-handedly boosted
Siege land viewership for all of n a the
fans even went as far to create a now
defunct website when does boloplay.com
since bolo came to pro league the views
for his games have just been absolutely
bananas so on his own bolo was pretty
much the be-all and end-all of Siege
despite his team's struggles but there
was one very important trophy missing
from bolo's cabinet the sixth
Invitational Hammer as TSM rolled into
2022 even with bolo on board a win at SI
looked like nothing more than a pipe
dream because of their lackluster
performance the na Squad had to win a
qualifier to even get to SI TSM had the
crossfires this really doesn't look
accomplishable for Melton he has got to
get the 4K of his life life but achieved
what's even from Long Haul true to his
name TSM are going to the sixth
Invitational and once they were in after
two years of struggling to stay relevant
TSM decided to bet everything on bolo so
what we did was we moved uh Beau to the
primary intro because you know Bo's
nasty one of the best teamers in the
game so why not
um and we knew uh we knew mark would be
fine on the flex rules at first the roll
swap seemed to really work the Merc
tries to find one but Pumba manages to
cut him down immediately it comes in
Geo's getting the plant down there's
somehow TSM have been able to steal
inside her sight and may just steal the
Round Here boa North there's a challenge
to be found embodied as he find it three
on the round for him going absolutely
while taking Hyper down Cuts Eclipse as
well 4K for ball or easy for TSM but
tsm's third place finish in their group
didn't bode well for the upcoming
bracket stage it was all on bolo and and
his teammates to put everything out
there it's four versus two it's all
Fallen apart in the last second moves he
gets one on back but he's going to go
absolutely huge Gio with the shutdown
TSM stop nip in round 12. he tries to
Peak the angle Merc he's not moving
anywhere he's going to keep himself put
sure is he gonna he knows now surely he
goes to the free fire does he get it oh
[__] comes out on top Andy come out on
top three versus two with Geo try and
sit the diffuser Nest coming in towards
bloopers big C4 over the top but it gets
shots out reset is down nesk has got to
do it all bolo steps up for the
challenge it's a little bit won't be one
of the close angle the bolo wins and
sends them further into the upper
bracket liquid drop down to the lower
but even after his Explosive Performance
against Team Liquid bolo didn't have the
time to rest on his Laurels TSM lost
their matchup with Empire and dropped
down to the lower bracket only to come
roaring back for a rematch after
eliminating FaZe Clan he's desperately
moving he's trying to do anything he can
but there comes the final kill and it's
a Flawless round at the end of a
Flawless before from TSM who will return
to any as Heroes regardless of the
outcome of the next mark because they
have got the region back into the grand
final of the sixth Invitational it was
do or die for TSM they had to beat
Empire no matter what I don't know if
Geo's gonna make it through yes he is
with the hair and he gets away first
kill goes to Bola Murphy finds one as
well Shepard rather tap tap pitter
patter of the MPX good enough for one
kill joystick is on pillars as well TSM
still of the advantage it's either with
one HP to be finished off from Merck and
joystick to clutch he's sitting on top
of the diffuser but he needs to be wary
because guess who's up top on that top
floor this could be an easy pick for him
flashes go in but they sail over his
head he's immune all of them read so
well by bolo and he's got two of them
with the diffuser down a third but no
Dan walks away from that Chala picks up
two big kills it's all up to Chala but
Dan can't get it we're going to overtime
again everything on the line for TSM
what a year it's been from them and it's
all now Shepherd to try and stop it
Empire have come so close before but
they've fallen short and they'll do so
again TSM said trust the process the
process just won you a world
championship
TSM are your six invitation National
2022 World Champs bolo had everything
he'd ever wanted he had reached the
absolute peak of competitive Siege but
having it all meant there was nothing
left to pursue that's all it was about
you know playing good for the year to
play good at SI and then it's like
what's beyond that you know not
necessarily like complacency I didn't
have complacency it was just kind of
like a is it the right choice for me to
continue bolo kept at it after all he
could still win another Invitational or
collect some trophies he didn't have yet
but unfortunately the rest of 2022
didn't live up to his SI Triumph pop-up
Geo walks in diffuser at hand there goes
flashes Geo tries to trade out Mark
actually prevails in that gunfight but
Gunner has the insurance policy snake
one of the newest members takes down Geo
but he doesn't get rexen Sonic's Pummel
TSM in the third map and after TSM
failed to even qualify for SI 2023
bolo's path forward because became clear
if you laid everything out on the table
and just looked at everything in a
critical mindset for my future for my
mental health for everything it was just
the time to time ago was the time to go
and it was a hard hard decision but
again I think overall from for
everything it's it's going to pay off
the only thing that truly made sense for
bolo was going back to where it all
started the scene isn't in that good of
a spot and now I'm kind of at like a
Crossroads it's like do I want to keep
sacrificing my brand my community That
Built Me Up and got me to this insane
level that I'm at right now or do I keep
kind of I guess staying with the sinking
ship the community was understandably
heartbroken the Bolos fans also
supported his decision and were quick to
show appreciation for his enormous
contribution to the growth and
development of their favorite games not
a lot of games have that where
you know the professional players are
also the game's biggest content creators
and when you can you actually when you
can actually connect those two worlds
you get something really good Ebola is
probably one of the arguably largest
largest legacies in Siege now what about
pengu what about sport what about Macy
what about psycho he had a comeback
story no I am talking about like beating
the game bro like this guy has a charm
million Subs on YouTube everybody that
plays Siege knows know who he is if he
streams more he's gonna grow his own
viewership he's got to grow Siege
viewership it's going to pull more
people into Siege you know so I think
it's just it's great for the game either
way just to have him in the ecosystem in
the community so you know just happy to
see him just driving but it isn't like
bolo was abandoning Siege entirely while
he is open to trying new things and
always has been Rainbow Six is still
going to remain his one true love for
the foreseeable future I'm not
completely saying that I'm done playing
competitively playing professionally
like that that route is all always going
to be open for me because I love I love
trying to be the best it's hard to say
exactly what the future holds for bolo
what is certain though is that his name
will forever be synonymous with Rainbow
Six Siege whether you watch his content
on YouTube or cheered for him On Lan and
if the past is any indication as long as
he keeps his eyes on the prize bolo's
dedication discipline and drive will
ensure that no matter what he ends up
pursuing it'll be a resounding success
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock